Hồ y kến người dân về dự án lớn vình, xây đảo nhìn tạo theo sự xây dự thành phố đả nắng,
hiện thành phố đăng sau các dự. Bản, ngành因c kiêu xây dự để ăn thí điểm một số câu chế,
chính sách đặc thủ nhằm phát triển đô thị động lực Quốc gia trên biển, chính Trung uường xem xét.
Trong qua chính xây dự để ăn và chính khai các thủ tục linh quan tiếp theo, các dự,
bản, ngành tiếp tục nghiên cứu kiểu lưỡng về yếu tổ địa chất, địa hình, thủy văn, dòng trải.
Đánh giá tỏng diễn các tắc đồng mua chường, cảnh quan, hệ sinh thái,
nhằm bảo đảm việc phát triển đô thức hiện một cách bình vướng,
2 hoa và hạn chế tối đá anh vượng đứng tự nhiên.
Sở xây dự thành phố đả nắng khẩm định, các ý kiến cóp ý,
sang kiến từ vui dân về dự án lớn vình sẽ được tiếp thủ nhìn tục,
trên đến các quan chức năng có thưởng quyền để làm cơ sở tham thảo trong quá trình hoàn thiện đi án.